i don't think his form has been as good
i mean it was brilliant and maybe it's
even his goals haven't been the same and
his goals have dried up a little bit so
that's why i was reluctant to say he is
the best player in the country i think
he'll get player of the year but i think
he'll get played of the year four you
think if if you will win you don't think
kevin des moines gets played
[Music]
how are you okay good you nice to see
you
what are we on today we represent him
i'm representing the mighty liverpool
today
painful and you are manchester city yes
come on let's do it man city will win
the premier league three
two one
[Laughter]
i think that was easy enough yeah isn't
it i don't see
any of the teams losing i must agree
with you the fact that liverpool have to
go to southampton tonight have to win in
the fa cup and get a result and then get
another result in hope manchester city
um drop some points against aston villa
at home this one's a slight element to
to with stevie and now i'm thinking
please please don't come back and upset
me stevie he's a legend in my eyes even
though he's liverpool but he could upset
me if he derails it
as a liverpool fan if steven yard is
winning liverpool the title that's by
beating city in the lineup
i don't think he gets the middle i don't
think he's good i think he's winning the
title he gets two medals
no i think i think with stephen going
back and all the playing stuff and of
course philip coutinho who was at
liverpool at the time
i think it's too much of um yeah of a
fairy tale isn't it and the big
overriding thing is that manchester city
are so good
so dominant i just cannot see it
happening at all if liverpool win the
quadruple they will be the greatest side
in english history oh
[Music]
the greatest in the history in the
history of course they are what happens
if they don't win not any more than that
that's not the question oh
yeah i've got to say agree i'm not
strongly agreeing if manchester city won
the quadruple i'd say they were the
greatest team yeah i know you would but
it just paid me to say that liverpool
could be could be the greatest team so i
was going to say agree yeah okay great
that's fair enough yeah
i strongly agree because it's never ever
happened they'll have played every
single game they've reached three finals
yeah liverpool has got a great history
you know and um they've won the treble
before and the great teams that have
gone before the great european history
yeah this this this team if they win if
they win four trophies i think it
surpasses anything yeah def i agree with
that to be fair it just pains me to say
oh i'll go agree then
if it's not them who would be the
greatest who would you guys have
currently as the best side ever
oh that's a good question
invincible's gotta be up there because
that's something that's never been done
before anybody who's done the travel i
think as football as we know how
difficult it is isn't it and if you win
three trophies in a year the invincibles
was superb not losing the game yeah so i
think if you can set a new record in
that respect what do you think it would
be harder to do now for these teams
do the treble
of invincibles probably invincible yeah
i think it's probably easier for these
two teams to win three trophies in a
season certainly in england it's hard
work isn't it it's hard hard work man
city won't be considered a big club
until they win the champions league
three
two
one
they're the favorites pretty much every
year in the champions league so how can
they not be considered a big club i'm
with you yeah i i think they are a big
club i disagree with the comments i
think they are a big club yeah i think
there's something about winning the
champions league to
propel them to this sort of not the next
level but to give them a little bit of
originality in the eyes of other people
that's all but i so the teams that i've
won 100 i understand why they're saying
that yes but i don't think it's because
they believe that i think it's just
because they haven't won it and that's
the only thing they have yeah
yeah with them at the moment i think
that a fantastic team the history is not
as as strong as other teams but that's
that's that's just football in general
exactly and it's coming yeah as long
did you guys think about patrice everest
comments about that they lacked big
characters oh yeah i think he's doing it
for the gram he's trying to be relevant
socially rather than believing that this
is a guy that's more chicken i know
come on
steve mcmanaman's team of players he
played with would beat julian lescott's
team of players that he played with oh
i'm going to liverpool no you played
with anybody oh anybody yeah he's yeah
he's winning
he's winning manchester united
don't know why he's winning because he's
got my favorite player of all time he
played with r9 so there you go though
we're done i'm not going out here i
disagree but i'm going to he's playing
with me and he's played against me
it'd be a
good game yeah
i wouldn't dare be
to say to say that but
yeah be good game but r9 taps it for me
there you go like if i'm picking
it's penny gets rio and and vinnie so
it's going to be tough it's our nine our
nine wins so i'm gonna say okay his team
wins strongly agree gosh if you play
with some players no no
yeah i mean they were brilliant i mean
it's just as you said you know when you
talk about the names of course they're
them yeah the big names the
you know well play of the year names and
stuff but you know it's um
you wouldn't necessarily say they'd beat
them just for the sake of it but yeah i
was very fortunate to play with a load
of really nice players yeah really good
players you're too modest
who's the uh who's the best player you
both played with
yeah tori i was saying like the best
footballer i played with was david silva
the best player i played with jaya
because i said if if he played well we
won yeah yeah he was done and that year
when he was everything he did he just
dragged that yeah
20 goals you think you've got 13 assists
yeah but what his past accuracy for the
season was 90 yeah yeah
for the season i know
he's a great player doesn't he and then
he just fallen out with pep is just
knocking a little bit you know it's
the order about him which is a pity
really because you're a lovely fella and
see who's the best player you play um
i played with zidane i thought he was
superb he was a great player and he
disagrees that he would win shut up
steve
next question next question
[Laughter]
steve you're not gonna like this one
either with your modesty there then no
no i don't i don't like saying things
like that yeah yeah wait to get this
one's even worse for you then so uh
steve mcmanaman is english football's
most successful export well that is true
that's facts yeah
it used to be the uk until gareth bale
won four
well yeah that's easy that's a fact
unfortunately unfortunately i am yeah
yeah there's a point of great pride for
you steve not particularly i'm not
bothered to be honest i don't believe
him that he's not bothered but i'm
bothered for him
i'm bothered
it's nice that people mention it but you
know that that'll be surpassed soon so
it doesn't really has it no but no but
not now but in the future someone will
go whether it's dudes or you know
someone will go abroad and win trophies
but dude's coming back no i know but
someone will go in it's like
i was the uk and then gareth went and
won four champions league so then it's
oh actually gareth is so now i'm
england's so
i think english teams are going to take
our talent
english our english teams will take
so and if that carries on great but i
just think it i don't get bothered about
it no one ain't going to madrid and
scoring in the final in the champions
league anyway i don't get bothered
so yeah it's a really nice thing but
it's all it's all good all right great
give me one of them questions
give jordan a quick give me some one of
them by the championship
mo salah has been the best player in the
premier league this season
very s very s
just half half of a grain and
and i'll say this because i think see
you in the league and i always think
say when you're picking like player they
should always come from the team that's
won the league picking the best player
and him not achieving what he's set out
to do
you know what i mean yeah um he's been
immense i think he's been different
though since he's come back from so do i
that's why i was a bit yeah that's why
he's been the same yeah because if he
had been i don't think he'd been
arrested as much as he has been
outstanding but yeah no i don't think
yeah i think from august to
december he was the standout player of
the year i know bernardo
silva played well but i thought he was
the standout player but i think since
the african nations
him losing to money in the final
and then the world cup qualifications
and him losing some money in the final
i don't think anything yeah i don't
think his form has been as good i mean
it was brilliant and maybe it's even his
goals haven't been the same and his
goals have dried up a little bit so
that's why i was reluctant to say he is
the best player in the country i think
he'll get player of the year but i think
he'll get player of the year four you
think if if he will win you don't think
kevin dubois gets played yeah because as
i said my i think i think player is
already done like it was when we when we
were playing i think it gets done quite
early doesn't it yeah you still got
doing too early yeah
february march exactly
so i think the fact that liverpool being
i've just won the fa court i'm getting
to the final of the champions league i
think they'll give it to a liverpool
player and i think likewise the ballon
d'or will be given to whoever wins it
benzema or and then if you don't think
he's on that
no
so i think benzema i think he's already
won it i just think if manny wins the
african nations and wins the fa cup and
the carabao cup and then wins the
champions league i think they bypass him
though do you think so yeah i think
they're buying even though i don't think
they should yeah well okay they do okay
i think they do him to winnie i think he
has to contribute to them when he yeah
where if real madrid just win winner
without benzema scoring yeah likewise i
think if real madrid win it
with the champions league i think
benzema definitely deserves to get it
but you're both the greatest between
salah and de bruyne for premier league
player of the year yeah i think i think
that is what it is that's what i that's
certainly what i'd say no one from
broadway like someone like son from god
no oh god no
i mean come on
for what i can hear that that's what i'm
saying tough goal scorer
cal walker is still england's best
choice at right back
three
two
one are we in a final or are we just
playing in a tournament let's say we're
in the we're in the knockout rounds of
the world cup gate still manager yeah
right yeah
over trend no i don't think he's a
better player than trent i just think
gareth southgate
airs on the on the side of caution all
the time and he plays too defensive for
me when i watch england i don't think
are you talking like rich james is in
there as well it's not just between them
two well no like but in regards to
what england need i think they need yeah
i would say kyle walker but if what but
if you if either of you ring a manager
right now i wouldn't pick carl walker
now
who would you pick that's what i'm
saying i'm thinking what game or what
game are we in let's say we're in the
they're in the quarterfinal of the world
cup against against the germany or
someone like that
that's the reason we got through is
because carl walker recovered
so yes he's in there i'm gonna go
strongly agree then if that's the case
if i was picking my right back
i'd go for someone
i'd go for reese or trent yeah i don't
understand that i understand that yeah
i see you there's no disrespect to
cowboys disrespect to any of them
they're all that level where you can't
disrespect anything
i agree with if it was me i would
disagree with yeah that's all i'm going
to agree because i still feel
england as a team are not liverpool or
city
do you think
england are two defensive minds when you
watch them play
no
if you were england mind you would you
play with five at the back i think
the formation suits the players we've
got i would personally when i watched
them get to the farm last year i'd like
them to be more who's your best-minded i
would have had i don't mind having kyle
walker as a right back i just i would
have always played before i wouldn't
have played with two sitting in the
field is it we had declan and calvin
phillips and i just thought it was too
negative against teams like that was my
personal opinion you know we got to the
final what do i know
last on pins yeah is there anyone who
you're looking at now go and they'll be
a surprise who could break into the
england squad for the world cup yeah for
the world cup wanna say jacob ramsey
hmm
i've seen him i know him work with him
do you work with him don't you his
reputation
his work ethic is good
mark and obviously connor are in there
but someone that's uncapped
not involved i want to say jacob he
moves like yaya tour it's a lot of
pressure jacobs hope you're listening
yeah yeah yeah but he moves like yaya
toure the current liverpool forward line
is the best strike force in premier
league history
family history
unique history
yeah i'll disagree with that as well you
know we're only talking about the last
couple of years and you sit here and
you're trying to think of the you know
the great forward lines aren't you in
the past
and then you think about the man united
forward lines tierrion ray and bear cam
from pillars and over mars they were
outstanding quickly forget about them
yeah because you're sitting here now
knowing seeing something from yeah
recently we know about it now i think
maybe in a couple of years if this if
the if they continue to be successful
maybe but i wouldn't just say it after
yeah yeah it's been there what four
months yeah jato got has been there 18
yeah i wouldn't make that statement it's
a big statement that in your own
personal opinion if you had to pick a
front two from premier league history
who would you pick any two triggers so
you're apparently
let's do that someone like shira and
henry or something shira's got to be in
the she asked to be in the conversation
because he scored them and he wasn't in
the best team yeah i'm gonna go cheery
was good he's in there cheered he was
brilliant i'm gonna go thierry and
aguero
oh actually
yeah oh yeah
was different prime time weather i know
what's the one i'm ready i can't i i
have to have
yeah you're going shira i have to have
sheila then yeah because yeah
how brilliant he was where's his where's
my shira yeah yeah yeah we're gonna go
on yeah i'm too old for i'm too young
yeah exactly yeah i'm a little bit too
old for wazza but being a scouser he
should have him in me i should have him
in you know yeah you're not
disrespecting me
yeah you know what i mean so henry i'll
go for andre
can go rooney yeah
but yeah erling holland will be the
premier league's top goal scorer next
season
i think if he stays fit
yeah if we're going on that then i'm
just going to say agree up i actually
think i think if he stays fit he could
be brilliant oh yeah i think he'd be
brilliant and i think liverpool's
forwards will spread it around a bit
more now
you think you'll just score more than
seller one of them might be moved on
next year one of the forwards i don't
know
because i don't think you can keep you
can't keep five happy candidates
waiting for signs first
one of them checks yeah so i think
liverpool will scatter their goals
across the board next year rather than
because mode hit the first five months
and sadio is it the last and i think
that'll go across the year because now
diaz has come in he'll score more goals
next year and i think they'll it'll be
dispersed across the board where i think
who thinks tom goschka for liverpool
next year
i think it'll be mo again because he
takes the pens yeah but i think harland
harland's yeah i think he'll outscore i
think he's takes pins next season i
think he's allowed to go to all of them
if he has a season like lukaku it'll be
a huge surprise yeah where because the
way they use manchester city play i
expect them to be
just a machine scoring goals we both
deserved more england caps oh i
definitely agree with that yeah
deserved
i want to say i wish i wish i had some
more but i was unfortunate my timing was
bad to be fair
i come in there it was seoul and seoul
stepped down it was
tyrion rio and i was just there just
waiting around for them and then
kind of finished around about the same
time i missed my opportunity probably
got more than i thought i was going to
get when i was starting out so it's not
good i i think only because when i was
starting out and getting into the
england teams
back then the club they controlled you
so there'd be times when i'd be called
off at england team and i'd be told
you're not going you have to stay here
you know when they'd be i'd go okay and
and that'll be it and then other times
you might have me captures it i had 37
yeah but in the end i should have had
more yeah you know it is what it is and
circumstances so as you said sometimes
you're on the subspecies you don't get
on
sometimes you should you think you
should be on and you're not on but it is
what it is i missed the world cup in
2002 i didn't get called into the squad
after we just won the champions league
you know you feel as if you should have
went but you know
maybe if i would have played better for
england
that i would have got picked but
sometimes it's just you know it was more
of a biased thing though where you had
to really be in england yeah exactly i
was playing in spain a lot and
you were playing in space do you pay for
rap
get the recognition yeah maybe did fan
come out to watch you much at madrid no
god nothing came out ever
i mean again don't get me wrong i wasn't
bothered that he never came out i mean i
certainly not sure in that in that i
think no but i may be wrong not that i
know off
but again i wasn't i wasn't that
bothered about he didn't need to come
out to um
not with technology until you know in
the early 2000s yeah just wouldn't you
need to go and see you just won the
champions league i don't think yeah i
have to say yeah what do we need to
confirm well if i'm scoring in the
champions league final what confirmation
maybe you just i should have played
better so
dude
me and patrick were like that it was a
physical battle we had so i didn't see
jared i didn't have that hatred for
gerard i wouldn't say i liked him but i
hate i didn't have that hatred for him
because maybe he was technically a
different type of player to patrick i
don't know well man united tried to sign
stevie gary went to a stevie's room at
england
but i would i would have waited
you and stevie well obviously he would
have been the resident